quand vous êtes devenu virologiste c'est
parce que vous avez choisi cette
spécialité parce que vous saviez à cette
époque qu'il y avait beaucoup de choses
à découvrir sénat domaine vraiment qui
s'ouvrait domaine qui explosait dans les
années 60 parce que les virus quand même
des petites choses assez simples
relativement par rapport aux
organismes aux cellules donc plus facile
dans l analyse et c'est pour ça que la
biologie moléculaire a commencé enfin
beaucoup fait progresser la virologie et
dont m vous vous lancez dans la grande
rue les expériences et vous dites un
certain moment que 90% des expériences
contente échoue ah oui ça c'est là c'est
l'ami du chercheur on est un petit peu
des pêcheurs stomp pêche alors il y en a
qui paient les petits poissons bien
acquis pêche et c'est qu'il est trop
poissons les gros poissons il est pas
souvent donc souvent on n'avait rien au
bout de votre ligne ouais donc aider il
ya des journées sans ya beaucoup de gens
naissant oui mais là pourquoi pourquoi
on échoue parce que parce qu'on est
partie de
wii ce qu'on croyait juste ne s'est pas
réalisé notre et l'hypothèse de départ
et était fausse et l'expérience avoue
bien l'expérience ratée pour des raisons
banal technique donc on doit recommencer
donc c'est une longue patience la
recherche essentiels vous avouez que
vous avez à cause du jeu c'est pas venue
d'une erreur vous avez vous avez raté la
découverte d'une enzyme qui a bouleversé
et effectivement il y avait la fameuse
11e reverse transcriptase transcriptase
inverse traduite de l'anglais qui était
qu'elle en une clé justement de ce type
de virus du virus du sida et qui
transcrit
son acide nucléique la rn en adn dans la
cellule et cet éden devait ensuite
s'intégrer dans les chromosomes la
source et une rose et l'extraordinaire
c'est lé cas trop bien à l'époque
effectivement on pouvait prédire
quelques personnes pouvaient prédire
cette envie d'exister et 2e 2-3 groupe
de laboratoires en fait l'on trouvé les
premiers oui mais vous auriez pu
j'aurais pu parce que j'ai pensé comme
les autres mais
quelle quelle est votre erreur l'erreur
c'est d'avoir pas persister ou n'est pas
dans les conditions adéquates pour faire
ça très rapidement c'est ça la
différence justement souvent au club des
états unis et la france et des états
unis avait un énorme potentiel pour
travailler très vite sur cette sorte
cette enzyme il suffisait d'écrire ou
téléphoner à
l'institut de la recherche américaine
pour avoir du virus 1 mg ou 2 mg de
sedan virus pas le cir du sida lazio qui
l'ait pas encore découvert mais un virus
analogues et on pouvait faire la
réaction entre les états unis je suis un
potentiel formidable pour trouver le
virus du sida c'est vous qui l'avez
trouvée oui alors là il ya d'autres
évidemment il ya pas que ça facilite les
moyens matériels facilite effectivement
il faut se trouver au bon endroit et au
bon moment enfin les américains s'y
trouve très souvent aussi il faut dire
que la science américaine est quand même
toujours la première du monde oui mais
alors à ce propos donc vous raconter
bien entendu et c'est passionnant
comment vous avez découvert le virus ont
pas le rétrovirus du du sida mais quand
on lit votre livre on se dit qu'il y
avait vraiment que vous et votre équipe
pour y croire au début oui parce
qu'effectivement personne ne pensait à
ce type il ya plusieurs familles dans
ces rétrovirus et personne ne pensait à
cette famille et ses petits donc là
l'hypothèse de départ était la bonne
c'est ça qui va payer dans l'hypothèse
de départ et l hypothèse d autres en
fait c'était l'hypothèse d'un rétrovirus
qui serait proche d'un virus qui
existait déjà qu'ils étaient découverts
dans l'équipe diallo qui s'appelait
lâcheté élevé et on a commencé à
chercher aussi en acheter les qu'est ce
qui vous a fait gagner vous est bien
c'est que je pense on avait un esprit
ouvert s'il voulait on n'avait pas de
d'à priori alors que l'équipe américaine
voulait à tout prix trouver un virus à
la langue à celle qu'ils avaient déjà
trop à celui qu'ils avaient déjà trouvé
c'est ça la grosse différence c'est ça
donc c'est ça qui vous a donné le et
puis le fait qu'on était en était bien
rodé j'avais réuni une petite équipe
depuis la fin des années 70 pour
chercher ce type de virus dans les
cancers ce qui m'intéressait c'est de
voir le régime virale de certains
cancers humains et donc nous étions nous
avions parfaitement la technique
parfaitement rodée pour chercher ce type
de virus et l'adapter très vite passer
du jour au lendemain au virus du sida on
avait des globules blancs de patients il
suffisait que de ses patients
donc soit disponible et là il ya aussi
effectivement des périodes de chance
enfin des occasions il ya d'une part là
on peut dire la pression d'applications
saas est important parce que c'est dans
la lignée exacte de ce que faisait
pasteur plaster travail est souvent
quand il y avait un problème pratique
qui se pose est effectivement on s'est
aperçu que
un rétrovirus pouvait exister dans les
plasmas utilisé pour fabriquer le vaccin
contre l'hépatite b donc les fabricants
qui est affiliée à l'institut pasteur
sont venus me voir pour me demander de
rechercher ce rétrovirus et de
l'éliminer et puis il ya eu aussi donc
un groupe de jeunes cliniciens en france
qui s'était constitué très vite pour
étudier les premiers cas de sida et qui
sont nus ils sont venus nous voir pour
travailler sur rechercher éventuellement
l'origine virale de l'or de l'or des
matériels de leur passion et à un moment
on écrit en lisant votre livre j'ai
écrit ma main j'ai dit le professeur
montagnier un caractère en or oui parce
que j'ai fait le recensement bon vous
demander des crédits et des locaux
l'institut pasteur vous refusez vous
envoyé un mémoire sur vos travaux à la
revue nature qui l'a revu la plus
célèbre revue d'une revue anglaise
refusait le haut vous allez à des
séminaires justement au moment où on
parle du sida on vous donne la parole au
dernier moment le dernier jour quand tu
es déjà les trois quarts des gens vont
déjà repris l'avion départ et je ne
parle pas alors là plutôt si parlons-en
de
scepticisme nos collègues français alors
ça fait quand même beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup mais nous savions parler
d'amertume d'orage de sueur sur cette
affaire-là gens parce qu on pense on
sait qu'on a là peut-être pas la vérité
parce qu'il ya pas de vérité en sciences
est absolument fin qu'on a quand même
fait un pas décisif dans ce dans la
connaissance de l'étiologie de l'origine
de cette maladie est effectivement au
début personne n'y croit mais ça c'est
tout à fait fréquents science oui mais
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas surpris c'est
le devoir de voir que tous à vos
collègues y compris gb d'après ce que
j'ai compris à l'institut pasteur se dit
bon montagne est d'accord il s'amuse et
mâcha mais c'est évidemment les
américains qui vont le trouver sera pas
lui bien sûr parce qu'il ya
effectivement une sorte de pression
mentale qu'elle est consciente au niveau
des chercheurs au père biologique s'est
passé mais voilà pourquoi dd c'est ce
qui va de registre il ya de remarquable
dans la découverte qu'a faite luc
montagnier avec son équipe jean claude
chermann et françoise barret c'est que
c'est un travail d'équipé qui a été fait
un pasteur et
sherman t elle travaille déjà depuis des
années pour essayer de découvrir le
virus des décennies et ils ont reçu un
jour de rosenbaum et d'autre un ganglion
que vous avez sur lequel vous avez
travaillé à l'intérieur duquel il avait
le virus quand il découvre le virus il
envoie le papier à gallo orgue à loket
un virologue de renom avaient déjà
découverts précédemment le virus
responsable d'une leucémie rare chez
l'être humain
si bien que gallo devant leur travail
alors a dit envoyez vite le papier moi
je fait paraître un grand papier dans
ses relances au mois de juillet au mois
d'août persuadé que le des virus qui
avait été découvert par montanier
sherman et bahebeck françoise marais
s'est elle même qu'elle siens et c'est
comme ça qu'il a accueilli la découverte
de l'équipe française dans son papier et
moi je me souviens avoir été un jour je
faisais partie de la commission
nationale d'éthique avoir défendu
le mou lave qui était la création de
votre équipe la fin de nos petits virus
et m'être fait contrer par des gens qui
ont du même nom le grand virologues
c'est diallo c'est le htlv 1 c'est à
dire ça c'est comme si un mal français
pour complément mais c'est incroyable ce
qu'il ya une équipe et personne ne le
croit parce si incroyable est-ce que
vous avez dû souffert comme nous avons
souffert pendant quelques mois et le
tient vraiment dans un tunnel j'ai déjà
dis d'ailleurs à mes collègues bon un
jour d'avoir la sortie du tunnel
effectivement on l'a vu à apparaître
des bus 84 gallou a confirmé
effectivement en redécouvrant le virus
bon pour la suite qui en fait des thèmes
celui qu'on lui avait envoyé ma fait la
stricte des d'autres souches également
la confirmation de gallo était quand
même important justement parce qu'elle a
convaincu la communauté scientifique et
ça c'est quand même quelque chose de
très important parce que pour que le le
public pour que les hommes politiques
soient convaincus il faut que la
communauté soit egis eau d'abord qu'on
aime et sas donc ç'a pris sa pris
quelques mois et on peut dire c'est
grâce à dix on a tout ce bruit qui s'est
fait aux états unis que a directement
notre découvrir de plus après en disant
bah oui on n'avait pas cru en vous des
collègues français ou étrangers très peu
très peu savent et c'est cet amour là
c'est assez dur la recherche à chacun à
la fin qu'au laboratoire est compétiteur
il faut bien voir c'est quand même des
travail d'équipé l'adie
professeur chanter le professeur chasse
elmer notre collègue effectivement c'est
une affaire d'équipé autrement on peut
pas tout seul tout cas suez
[Musique]